hello everyone and welcome to round five
of the US Championship 2023 we have an
incredible game between Andrew tang and
Fabiano Carana and I wasn't sure whether
I should show this game as a tutorial or
as an actual game that was played
because it works quite well for both and
I decided to you know invest in some
lines because they're really really
awesome and you guys will learn a lot on
how to face the London system uh even
though I already made a tutorial on how
to play against the London system this
uh what Fabby played here is uh well
nothing short of Sensational and uh
pretty much all the games except one
ended in in a theas result only one game
ended in a draw but I decided to show
Fab's game first as he is currently the
leader of the US Chess Championship so
let's check it out everyone of course
knows both of them Andrew Tang um you
know he's an incredible bullet player
incredible hyper bullet player an
incredible Ultra bullet player but this
is classical here you have to slow down
a little bit and also you know play very
precise moves when you play a player of
um karan's caliber so let's check it out
Andrew opens with D4 we have Knight to
F6 and Bishop to F4 uh we have Pawn to
G6 by Fabby Knight to C3 and pawn to D5
and here we have Pawn to E3 uh going for
the London system setup and usually
everyone uh just plays Bishop to G7 here
it's almost exclusive and Andrew already
played one lond assisting game against
leavon Aran where Leon played Bishop to
G7 and the game continued um Knight to
B5 maybe you saw it in round three going
after C7 leavon played Knight A6 and
Andrew went back with the Knight leavon
went back and here they just drew on
repetition after a couple of moves but
Fabby says uh not so not so fast he
plays Knight to H5 and there are a
couple of Blitz Games online by Maxim
chab that where this moves move was
played but when it comes to classical we
can uh safely call this a completely new
game so Knight H5 going after the bishop
and Andrew has to decide whether he
leaves the bishop there at um for Fabby
to double his F Pawn does he go back
with Bishop to G3 or does he attack The
Rook with Bishop to E5 also Bishop to G5
is an idea uh First bishop to E5
attacking the rook and Fabby plays Pawn
to F6 okay the bishop has to go back
Bishop to G3 and now Pawn to C6 just uh
strengthening his Center uh as he is
preparing Knight to D7 so the queen will
not be defending the D5 Pawn he wants to
play Knight to D7 and pawn to E5 and
look at how difficult it is for white to
actually play this bishop to D3 uh very
normal move Knight to D7 and now we have
Bishop to H4 and here I allowed the
engine to Crunch the numbers to like
depth 50 because it's a such a new
position and such a wild one and the
engine says okay you can play it but
nothing spectacular for white even with
B White's best move Pawn to E4 uh Fabby
will still strike with Pawn to E5 and
after d captures on E5 he will play D
captures on e4 and now look at this
bishop captures on e4 Knight captures on
G3 H captures and now Knight captures on
E5 Faby solves all of his developing
problems now both of the Bishops can get
into the game uh the queen uh has all
the squares the queen wants and even if
white trades Queens um then it's you
know not a problem the king will just
capture and if you try something like
Queen T2 then even King to F7 uh that's
what's possible also C6 very useful as
you don't have Bishop to E5 check and if
Rook to D1 attacking the queen even
Queen to B6 and now it's uh uh it's
actually white who will be in some
problems if you try F4 then just Knight
to G4 the Knight is defended and your
king is on E1 not the best for white so
uh even with perfect play this is not
easy to play for white but Andrew played
Bishop to H4 uh we have Pawn to E5 by
Fabby and now his idea on how to meet
Pawn to E5 was Bishop to E2 he attacks
the Knight here okay Fabby goes back and
now he goes go Pawn to E4 and now we
have this very cool setup in the center
uh Queen to B6 Fab goes after White's
weaknesses the B2 pawn and the D4 Pawn
uh e captures on D5 uh it's a very
useful move because uh it frees up the
E4 Square for the White Knight so if you
play something like Queen captures on B2
then Knight E4 and you're already uh
putting pressure D6 is is you know
something to be consider that the D F6
Pawn is hanging D4 square is all in all
a great Square for the Knight and also
you don't have to if Bishop to B4 with
check King to F1 if you're a London
player of course you don't shy away from
playing King to F1 it's very normal uh
but after he captures on D5 uh Fabby
said nope thank you for the F5 Square he
played Knight to F5 and the bishop on H4
is undefended but okay a nice Vision to
uh D captures on C6 first going after
the Knight here B captures and now
Knight to F3 defending the bishop you
could also move the bishop back but you
also want kind of want to develop your
pieces as your entire King side is
undeveloped and here Fabby grabs it
Queen captures on B2 this is uh comes
with tempo as the Knight is hanging
Knight to E4 and now Knight captures on
H4 Knight captures on H4 and now while
you could go for the pawn right away Fab
first win some space Here pawn to F5 and
now H you don't really have a good
Retreat if you go back with Knight to G3
then Queen to C3 check is very annoying
not all low to do you cannot block with
the queen as the r hangs and once you
move the king uh you're never castling
and you will have uh serious issues
bringing this Rook into the game another
thing you could do after F5 is something
like Knight to D2 but then the queen no
longer guards the pawn it's a free Pawn
you you enjoy your massive Center and um
you don't really have the option of
castling as the Knight on H4 is hanging
so you you can't Castle here so Rook to
B1 attacking the queen and now only now
Queen captures on D4 Fabby trades Queens
Queen captures e captures and now the
Knight is still hanging Knight to D2 so
fab is up a pawn and uh he keeps the
initiative he goes Knight to B6 uh and
um the question is should you Castle or
not uh well you could but Andrew first
goes for the uh he fixes the position of
his Knight and goes after the D4 Pawn
but Fabby doesn't defend it with
something like Pawn to C5 he plays
Bishop to E6 and goes after the A2 pawn
and now the problem is uh you kind of
have to allow this there's no good way
to actually defend the pawn if A3 then
just queenside castles the pawn is
nicely defended and this will always be
weak so you don't really have a good
Pawn push and and uh uh there's just no
good way to to to keep the pawn so he
does go for the trade Knight captures on
D4 Bishop captures on A2 this creates a
past a pawn for Fabby uh Rook to C1 and
now Bishop to H6 and now look at the
mighty Bishop fair just you know
reigning Supreme like it's uh like it's
their show uh Pawn to C4 the pawn is
nicely defended even if you capture the
Knight as the bishop and Rook are
defending the pawn but now just Queens
side Castles by Fabby and now the only
way for any and to continue this is Rook
to C2 but it's not a very nice move to
play because you have to trade here Rook
captures captures and now after Rook to
E8 the king is stuck in the center of
the board there's just no good way to uh
to Castle to safety so instead we have
Knight for to F3 adding another Defender
here and now just Rook H to E8 the
absolute strongest move keeps the king
in the center of the board uh and Here
Andrew went for Rook to C2 which does
seem like it should be better now than
in the variation where I've shown it but
now it's actually
completely winning for Fabby uh but you
have to see really really far and deep
into the position which of course you
can as you are comfortable in your own
homes as I imagine uh feel free to pause
the video and win the game for Fabby
while I give you a couple of
seconds so uh for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on finding
this spectacular idea and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is Knight to A4 incredible but it's true
and uh just to give you an example of
how far it goes and of course
congratulations to everyone who found
this you are an exceptional player uh I
I actually have no idea how you found
this uh the idea is that after Rook
captures an A2 there's Knight to C3 now
you're attacking the rook and of course
threatening Rook captures on E2 and once
The Rook moves you even play Rook
captures on E2 check King to F1 and now
Rook D captures on on D2 Knight captures
on D E2 and now Bishop captures on D2
that's the point you are defending
everything here and you might think well
let's just remove the defender of The
Rook shouldn't this be a nice draw for
white well not really because if you
play this then you get to Checkmate on
E1 so uh Fabby saw all of this and he
calculated that Rook captures on A2 is
not even an option to be considered for
for Tang so he played Pawn to H4 with
some ideas of maybe bringing the Rook
into the game this way uh but it doesn't
work Bishop to G7 this uh uh just
prevents everything and now Knight to C3
will even be defended by the bishop and
if you go for Rook captures on A2 now
then it's a different idea Knight to C3
and after Rook to C2 Rook captures on E2
check King to F1 and now okay you don't
have the bishop here like in the line
that we just discussed but white has no
moves Pawn to A5 and there is no
stopping this Pawn white white has no
counterplay here if you try to bring the
Rook into the game Rook D to E8 is now
coming now this Knight is paralyzed as
well due to Rook the E1 Checkmate and if
you play G3 okay you uh free up the G2
Square for the king but A4 and you
cannot stop this the Knight covers day
two the bishop covers day one if needed
this is game over so instead after
Bishop to G7 Andrew played castles it is
uh his last attempt of getting back into
the game but now Faby just plays Knight
to C3 H attacking the bishop while his
Bishop on A2 is defended Bishop to D1
and here Fab just played Pawn to A5 and
he was in this position and move 27 that
and Andrew Tang resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here so
he managed not to lose material he
managed the castle but now once you look
at the position you're probably thinking
okay why did he resign there's I mean
okay he's down a pawn but is it that
severe uh there's no move white can make
here that's how how well Fabby played
this you can't move
anything none of the pieces can move the
Knight can't move because the uh Bishop
on D1 would hang you can't really move
this Rook if you play something there's
really nothing to try play Rook to D E1
you can just capture it and then after
Knight captures the bishop on D1 is
undefended and after this okay you can
capture on A2 but now Knight to C3
attacks the rook and once The Rook moves
now you play Pawn to A4 everything the
same only you know a few pieces less but
the pawn is Unstoppable uh you can try
something like Knight um Knight E2 F3 A3
and after Knight to B3 sort of guarding
the A1 Square uh Rook to D1 with check
and okay King to H2 point Pawn to A2 and
next you're going to promote the pawn to
a queen win the Knight and of course
completely winning so even if you play
the absolute best moves uh that you know
the the engine plays
um it's still very clear how how you
lose this terribly so of course Andrew
had enough of this and he decided to
resign so only 27 moves and um I'm
really really impressed with this I I've
seen some lines where you counter the
London with Knight to H5 just never
never quite like this uh maybe Bishop to
E5 is just too optimistic just allowing
this free F6 move and then Pawn to C6 uh
just beautiful beautiful stuff preparing
Pawn to E5 it looks like it should not
be possible to play something like this
like you ruin your king side you put the
Knight on H5 you play C6 you play E5 D5
uh but it holds and if you guys have
problems playing against the London
system uh do try this looks looks uh
absolutely incredible of course you know
you have to know a lot of lines uh but
um uh you know
if you if you if you struggle against
the London maybe maybe this is for you
if not do try my system first link in
the description below maybe you guys uh
will like that one uh but yeah very
nicely done by Fabby he went into this
round as the leader and he comes out of
this round as the leader so after five
rounds it is Fab H is leading the
tournament we're going to see at least
one more game I'm looking at um leevon
Aran versus Hans nean uh if you guys
have any others that you would like to
see also use hashtag suggestion but
probably that game is coming up next uh
so yeah that's the game hope guys
enjoyed it I would like to thank Mr
hoody Guy Peter Marino an anonymous
person Roger Stone no need to mention me
in the video for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the US just
Championship uh until it finishes uh so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your
day